sea fx iguala a x a la n más b por x +
12 todo eso dividido en 13 x x elevado a
la m más d por x más 12 donde m yenes
son números naturales y a b c y b son
constantes desconocidas nos preguntan
cuál de las siguientes opciones es una
posible gráfica de igual a efe de x por
supuesto como siempre las líneas
punteadas indican a síntomas verdad y
aquí nos muestran nuestras cuatro
opciones de gráficas para de igual a efe
de x verdad entonces como siempre te
invito a que hagas una pausa resuelva
este problema por tu propia cuenta y
después vamos a hacerlo juntos pero no
tenemos que esto es muy interesante
verdad porque no nos dieron mucha
información así que este será un
problema bastante interesante de hecho
no sabemos ni el valor de estos
exponentes verdad nivel
de los coeficientes así que bueno trata
de resolverlo
muy bien vamos a hacerlo ahora todos
juntos como como ya hemos dicho nos
dieron muy poca información así que
podemos notar que solamente nos dieron
esta información estos números dos de
verdad y estos parecen ser una gran
pista así que por ejemplo fijémonos que
no podemos hallar las raíces de esta
función verdad ni siquiera podemos
encontrar digamos cuando es que el
denominador se anula sin embargo estos
números 12 nos dicen exactamente qué
pasa si x igual a 0 puesto que si x es
igual a 0 todos estos otros términos se
cancelan verdad entonces nosotros
podemos calcular la función f evaluada
en cero y obtendríamos cero
b x 0 que es 0 + 12 y luego esto va
dividido en 13 x 0 que 0 + de x 0 que es
0 + 12 verdad entonces esto simplemente
será 12 dividido entre 12 que es una
verdad entonces así al menos sabemos
quién es digamos el valor de la
intersección de la función con el eje
más bien de la gráfica de la función con
el eje y así que veamos si esta
información es suficiente para
determinar cuál sería la gráfica y aquí
tenemos nuestras cuatro opciones veamos
qué pasa primero con el caso de la
gráfica a verdad aquí la intersección
con el eje y se encuentra en dos verdad
y nosotros dijimos que la intersección
debe ser en 1 así que esta opción
tenemos que descartarla ahora bien
veamos qué es lo que pasa con b aquí se
encuentra 2 y vemos que más o menos a la
mitad verdad se encuentra el 1 y es
justo donde intersect donde inter se k
gráfica al eje de verdad entonces parece
ser que la opción b es una buena opción
veamos qué pasa con la opción c aquí
podemos ver que la intersección se da en
sería que es menos 2 no sería
2 468 aquí sería menos 2 verdad entonces
la intersección con el eje y es menos
dos cosas que no queríamos verdad porque
queremos que sea en de igual a uno y la
opción de ni siquiera tiene
intersecciones con el eje y así que está
esta forma la información suficiente
verdad la información que nos dieron fue
suficiente para suerte nuestra porque en
realidad no nos dieron mucha información
más que cuánto vale la función digamos
en cero verdad así que en realidad no
podríamos hallar las raíces ni las
cintas verticales u horizontales ni las
discontinuidades removibles así que
definitivamente nos quedamos con la
opción b para suerte es nuestra